Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
With the recent ascendancy of several new
AI-based techniques for human facial reenactment,
we are now able to create videos where we
transfer our gestures onto famous actors or
politicians and impersonate them.
Clearly, as this only needs a few minutes
of video as training data from the target,
this could be super useful for animating photorealistic
characters for video games and movies, reviving
legendary actors who are not with us anymore,
and much more.
And understandably, some are worried about
the social implications of such a powerful
tool.
In other words, if there are tools to create
forgery, there should be tools to detect forgery,
right?
If we can train an AI to impersonate, why
not train an other AI to detect impersonation?
This has to be an arms race.
However, this is no easy task to say the least.
As an example, look here.
Some of these faces are real, some are fake.
What do you think, which is which?
I will have to admit, my guesses weren't all
that great.
But what about you?
Let me know in the comments section.
Compression is also an issue.
Since all videos you see here on YouTube are
compressed in some way to reduce filesize,
some of the artifacts that appear may easily
throw off not only an AI, but a human as well.
I bet there will be many completely authentic
videos that will be thought of as fakes by
humans in the near future.
So how do we solve these problems?
First, to obtain a neural network-based solution,
we need a large dataset to train it on.
This paper contains a useful dataset with
over a 1000 videos that we can use to train
such a neural network.
These records contain pairs of original and
manipulated videos, along with the input footage
of the gestures that were transferred.
After the training step, the algorithm will
be able to pick up on the smallest changes
around the face and tell a forged footage
from a real one, even in cases where we humans
are unable to do that.
This is really amazing.
These green to red colors showcase regions
that the AI thinks were tampered with.
And it is correct.
Interestingly, this can not only identify
regions that are forgeries, but it can also
improve these forgeries too.
I wonder if it can detect footage that is
has improved itself?
What do you think?
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!